[Music]
all right and welcome back to the road
to 2000 my name is caleb done be back
here again streaming for the second time
today this time though I'm not playing
anybody I'm just going to be teaching
some chess so what I want to look at
today is actually going to be minority
attacks which can arise from a few
different openings but so we're gonna be
looking at some of the most common ones
especially from you know the Queens
gambit declined structures the Carlsbad
pawn structure so for our first game
here today I've got a game between pal
Benko and Mark taimanov which was played
back in 1960 as we just found out and
yeah let's let's take a look at how this
game got started here so we started off
with one c4 e6 g3 d5 so right now we've
got an English where White's going to
think I know this Bishop but we'll see
pretty soon it actually transposes hi
welcome transposes over to a Queen's
Gambit structure with white playing
Bishop g2 so slightly different than the
normal Queens gambit declined but you
know it's gonna be the same structure so
we see black castle C takes d5 he takes
d5 Bishop g5 h6 Bishop takes Bishop
takes Knight c3 Knight back to e7
you know this pond was feeling some
pressure so black retreats this night in
an effort to you know add another
defender to this pawn it's very common
actually in these structures with this C
pawn on c7 you don't really want this
knight on c6 kind of blocks the pawns
options you know it usually wants to
Vance IV to c5 or even c6 but we'll see
after work c1 again putting pressure on
this pawn this pawn does come to c6 and
black has this nice pawn chain here
right and so for a long time in chess
you know this this pawn structure was
thought to be you know fine for for
black confine for white maybe white has
a slight edge because he has to
Center pawns compared to Black Swan but
it wasn't until relatively recently that
this minority attack idea was discovered
by relatively recently I mean probably
around 100 years or so this idea has
been been known and especially in the
1930s I think this idea was seeing a lot
of play and we'll definitely take a look
at a couple games from that era as well
but you know this structure for a long
time looked very solid for black right
very solid there's not really any
weaknesses to attack maybe you know
white can try and hit this b7 pawn
somehow but you know it's not so easy
right it's a closed file but eventually
you know players discover this idea of
using this pawn minority compared to
this pawn majority to launch an attack
and create some weaknesses so you know
does anybody here is anybody familiar
but this minority attack and how it
commonly is played yeah Evan yeah you
play B for aiming for b5 and taking on
c6 so yeah and the idea of course is you
would get rid of this b7 pawn forced
them to come to b6 when it's on a
half-open file and you're can easily
attack it it also you know in addition
to weakening the c6 bond weakens the c5
square right once this b7 pawn is gone
it can no longer advance to b6
preventing any piece from landing on c5
so it really makes it difficult for
black to deal with this weakness and so
we're gonna take a look at a few games
today that center around this kind of
idea using the pawn minority to create a
weakness or to give your piece of
squares so white wasted no time here
Bunco played b4 and of course black
didn't want to allow b5 quite so easily
so he plays this a6 move white continues
with a 4 you know really trying to push
through and black played Knight f5 here
you know cuz there's no real way to
prevent this b5 move from happening
anymore
you can try to add another you know
defender of the square with something
like Bishop to d7 but this isn't really
a move you
dying to play white probably has a
couple options here one of which might
just be advancing b5 anyways maybe you
could prepare it a bit more with
something like III followed by Queen b3
putting pressure on d5 there's a little
supporting the b5 break but either way
you know black decided this isn't what
he wanted to do he played nine f5 and
white again wastes no time follows
through with this plan plays b5 we see
black respond with rook e8 and I want to
do it your thoughts on this move you
guys have probably seen this before in a
lot of your games and so what do you
think you know black usually does in
response to this b5 move here something
happens pretty commonly for black
especially in this specific structure
any ideas has to do with you know
finding a nice way to activate his
pieces even if white is going to get
this this pawn breakthrough see youtube
chat any ideas they're talking about
illegal moves that's good it's good it's
good to determine the legal moves before
you determine the good ones really what
would you play is black here though just
shout anything out what are your ideas
yeah a b5 it's it's a common move and
the reason is you know white has vacated
the a1 square with his rook he's brought
it over to c1 to put more pressure on
this
c6 pawn but you know that leaves the a
file behind and so if White's going to
let the AF file open
you know black usually takes that
opportunity even if he doesn't invade
with the Zurich right away or even ever
you know later on he can use this file
to his advantage or at least buy some
time while white has to deal with I mean
any threats that might appear on this
file so it's kind of strange to me that
black chose not to open the save file
because you know I really do think that
this was a the right way to go for him
instead he just plays rook e8 putting a
little bit of pressure on the ski pawn
but allowing white to just capture on c6
and after black captures on c6 now you
know the circus staring at nothing right
and it actually saddles white with a
weakness on a 4 maybe after something
like Bishop D
seven there's some c5 ideas you know
with the discovery on this pawn but it
also settles black with a weakness right
black is gonna have to be careful about
both this a6 pawn and the c6 pawn now
and so we'll have to see if white was
able to make use of this idea where
black ended up with kind of two
weaknesses over there whereas he could
have just left himself with one and a
more active rook by taking on b5 so
right away
white realized where his pieces belong
so I talked a little bit about what was
weakened by removing this b7 pawn and
one of those things was the c5 square
right so something white would love to
do is to put a piece on this c5 square
so how do you think white can best
achieve this you know specifically maybe
he wants a knight on c5 so let me hide
this notation here so no uh no cheaters
but not that I would accuse you of
anything but you know he probably wants
to put a knight on this square right it
nit aims nicely at this pawn on a6 and
it's a you know prevents the pawn from
pushing to c5 and any you know event
that that might happen so let's try and
find a path for either one of these
nights
yeah Knight d2 to b3 it is a great way
to go about it first off you know you
have to deal with this pawn though so
maybe III here would be a move right
followed by maybe Knight d2 to b3 and we
do see e3 in the game actually and white
continues or black continues with h5
actually so with h5 on the board you
know if you move this night away maybe
black is planning to you know push this
guy through and it might be kind of
uncomfortable you know it's nice to have
this night here at least for the moment
kind of defending this square so benko
actually decided he wanted this other
night to come to c5 and so with that in
mind what path do we see open up now
yeah you can't come to a four right
because this ponds kind of in the way so
maybe this was part of you know blacks
idea of leaving this pond on the board
it kind of hampers White's pieces and
we'd like to push it to a five so we
have this scarf for a night but
unfortunately you know this the squares
is still defended Nyepi one would be
kind of an ugly way to do it right you
can come back to d2 and over to b3 but
you know you don't really want to be
wasting this much time so you found a
slightly better way
any path any path to see five who can
find the path the banco chose
so yeah again we could use this night
but it's doing a nice job kind of on f3
right it's helping control this d4 pawn
it's helping control this h4 squared
it's helping defend our King even
against a lot of threats
whereas this Knights kind of just
sitting in the way I know we'd like to
move it use our rooks to help attack the
C pawn and so this is kind of the night
we want to improve because this knights
already pretty well placed has chances
later on to even come into e5 and you
know add a key attacker to this the C
pawn again kind of an ugly path though
right we don't really want a sideline or
night so maybe 92 right 92 coming to f4
with tempo on this week pawn and then
coming over to d3 or it controls both
key squares and can kind of decide from
there where it wants to go
so nobody got that actually nobody's
nobody watching this lecture is as good
as pal Benko I can't believe it I had a
lot of faith in you guys so black played
Queen to d6
of course you know the spawn was
attacked so we had to deal with it and
now again we bring this night with tempo
to f4 but you know you know black was no
slouch mark taimanov of course a very
strong player so he's got ideas of his
own right he's not gonna sit around and
let white make 8 moves with his knight
and get it over to c5 and take all his
free pawns you know he's a bit better
than that so he wants to open the Kings
side right it's very common when you see
your opponent playing on one side of the
board you want to kind of counter-attack
either in the center or the other side
of the board so that's what taimanov is
aiming for here and with this in mind
what do you think white chose to do here
just continue with this plan or is
something else you want to trade Knights
by taking this pawn so taking the pawn
would be kind of interesting now the
problem is you can kind of you know take
this pawn back right away so you're not
actually winning upon and the other
thing is you've kind of opened up your
King a little bit right and this is what
black is really hoping for you know he
wants your King to be open on the Kings
side which is why you played this aged
[ __ ] move if we were to play something
like Knight to d3
this wouldn't be terrible but already
it's getting kind of shaky right you
know suddenly this F pawn is controlling
a lot of squares that maybe it's it's
not prepared to control all of them you
know we might start seeing ideas like
Knight takes g3 maybe not in the
immediate position but it's definitely
already an idea the ideas of bringing
this bishop in ideas of bringing this
rook and again it probably doesn't work
immediately but so you start seeing you
know things are starting to shake loose
for white so Benko decided you know he
didn't want all these squares to be
quite so weak so what do you think he
played here
yes so something like c3 is what you're
saying
c3 c5 yes so you want to ignore him this
other way and just kind of continue with
the attack if I understand correctly
right but you know like I said Benko
wasn't so happy with you know allowing
this pawn to take on on g3 I think white
would be fine with something like hurt
to c3 erect to c5 because I do think you
know for the moment he has enough pieces
helping defend his King but uh maybe
best is actually what Benko played which
is going to be people in the YouTube
chatter are saying it G 4 I think
Riddick's said that first and maybe a
mr. Alvarez coming and table ela problem
as well so this is kind of a great move
it stops black from ever opening any
part of the Kings side it keeps it shut
down on the side where the opponent is
trying to play and this is a pretty
common idea you want to keep things
closed where your opponent is trying to
attack and you want to open things up
where you're trying to attack you want
to create weaknesses and this move kind
of prevents black from making anymore
weaknesses right we see the interesting
move g5 thrown in this night of course
can't go to h6 because you know pawn g5
would be played for white and it can't
really come to e7 either because again
pawn g5 would simply be winning a piece
which is why we saw black throw-in this
g5 move but white simply moves this
night away now and after your Knight to
e7 plays h3 and we'll see that you know
these pawns are kind of locked together
now and so what's the only way well I
could try to open up this this Kings
side anymore what's the only pawn break
you would have yeah f5 but we can
already see f5 is going to be you know a
ways off in the distance right f5 is not
going to be easy to achieve if you ever
move this bishop you might leave this
pawn behind which is not something black
would want to do and it's tough to add
another defender to this pawn actually
all those pieces are kind of awkwardly
placed
you can try something like Knight to g6
maybe but you know once again already
White's going to have you know a lot of
pressure on the Queen side and you still
are a couple moves away from achieving
anything like this
you know maybe Queen to d8 to add
another defender but then you're leaving
this pawn behind so maybe you have to
play Bishop d7 first or something but
you know it's just very obvious that
your plan is going to be a lot slower
because White has opted for this change
in structure so it's a very nice find by
Benko to kind of slow down blacks attack
so let's see what happened in the game
in the game we actually did see Knight
g6 and now white as you were saying just
adds pressure to this pawn forcing black
to play something like Bishop d7 to
defend it and now we see this knight
finally come to its you know destination
that had in mind ever since you know a
few moves ago it's attacking this pawn
it's threatening to capture this Bishop
and capture this pawn it's doing quite a
lot on this square and now we see rook
to c8 of course you know he had to deal
with this threat of takes and takes so
he just adds another defender in that of
the rook of course white doesn't want to
take now because you know the night is
leagues better than this Bishop and he
goes for rook e1 instead
eyes forced his opponent's pieces into
kind of defending their pawns awkwardly
and so now he's trying to get in where
you know he can black actually cannot
challenge this file if he challenges
with this rook will simply take and if
rook takes the pawn hangs and if Queen
takes of course the bishop hangs so
black is already kind of helpless right
he's made simply too many weaknesses
it's forced his pieces into awkward
places and you know something is
eventually going to fall if white just
keeps improving his pieces
so we see black simply played Bishop e8
getting this Bishop off of this attacked
square so now we can finally on the next
turn perhaps challenge this file so
white just simply continues with a5
making a strong hold on this b6 square
preventing this pawn on a6 from going
anywhere keeping it firmly under the
control of this night we do see
rictus e7 what might happen on rip to b8
here what do you think
yeah this one's pretty easy for white to
deal with right we'd simply capture this
rook again if Rick takes this pawn on a6
is falling yet let me make sure that's
actually true we do have to deal with
rook a a if we are to play this line it
feels like we should have something that
we're able to do here is simply Knight
to c5 right and then if FERC takes we
have Knight be 7 so the a pawn would in
fact fall and if Queen to b8 we just
have to be 1 and again we're coming in
to this d6 square maybe attacking this
pawn a lot we can even add more
attackers now which is why we simply
start to c7
from mark time enough this trick does
come in to b6 coming in you know
attacking both weaknesses at the same
time and after Rick a7 kind of the only
legal move to defend this pawn again we
simply see white bring even more pieces
into the game and you know already this
is this is hopeless for black and it's
kind of just visually clear right he has
two rooks stacked up defending a single
pawn with no extra space he has a bishop
stuck on EI only defending at the other
pawn this Knight is you know in a
different world this Knight is well
placed to advance the attack but
obviously with all these pieces
dedicated solely to defending these
pawns you know this Knight is doing
nothing actually on g6 this Bishop is
stuck looking at its own pawns maybe
someday in the future it would like to
come to d8 but that's not happening just
yet and on the other side of the coin if
you look at White's pieces they're
really well placed you know this is
going to just fall apart for black black
tries Knight to e7 bringing in another
defender and white simply plays Bishop
f1 like I said adding another attacker
to this a pawn and now it's impossible
to add another defender actually
so after Knight to b8 we saw the rook
capture in the bishop capture and white
is simply up upon his pieces are still
far more active than his opponents
obviously and
you know the game ended shortly after we
saw Queen d8 attacking the spawn a
single time so white captures and pushes
gets this rock into b7 attacking this
bishop I don't think you have time to
take this piece for example something
like Knight to g5 I think would be game
ending no real way to defend this h7
Square you can try something like f5 but
now maybe I'll just capture and play
Queen e7 and mate will follow so after
the bishop was attacked time enough
defended the bishop we see a7 come now
Bishop f8 and now let's see I think some
shenanigans started happening here try
and find a good move for white I'll ask
you before I before I show it obviously
almost everything ones here but Benko
found some fun tactics - in the game I
think yeah something like 96 right I'm
not sure if that's exactly what was
played first we saw coming out 5
actually but with the same idea here
96 would be possible because of course
if you take checkmate but maybe there's
some queen c8 but Seidelman I really
don't see it for black i think 96 would
have won banco chose a different path
with queen f5 and after Bishop e7 he
actually sacrificed on g5 and with the
same idea of 96 coming this time as a
fork so black moved his queen of course
this is still checkmate after Queen age
7 and Queen h8 or 27 whichever you
prefer so he has to move the Queen Benko
simply takes on f6 now rather than takes
on g5 which would just be a trade and 97
and the stork has nowhere to go he takes
on a 7 white takes on a 7
and here black resigns finally threw in
the towel you might think he has two
bishops maybe you can try to hold but
one of these bishops is going to die
unfortunately along with the rest of the
pawns so no way out for time enough
there so that game would be very bad for
black right it all went kind of horribly
wrong and I did mention the fact that
black could have taken on b5 but by no
means was he losing after he chose not
to take on b5 so what do you think
actually went wrong for black there it's
kind of tough to tell right you know he
was just playing moves and then all of a
sudden White's pieces were everywhere
and his pieces were nowhere right yeah
that's a great point
he went for this attack oh let's see
here just kind of starting here you know
right after e3 he went for this attack
with h5 and H 4 butts I kind of missed
how slow it was going to be right and so
he kind of dedicated this Bishop in this
knight in this Queen to aiming at the
Kings side but then he ended up
dedicating his two rooks in this other
Bishop to defending on the Queen side
and it kind of resulted in a position
where he couldn't really achieve either
so I do kind of agree that this h5 move
was kind of a start at the downfall what
could black have played instead do you
think there's a couple choices
a-five trying to play Bishop a6 yeah
this is actually a great plan once again
this would actually you know kind of
lock the white pawn on this a Foursquare
whereas in the game we saw it come to a5
and put more pressure on a 6 and c6 kind
of indirectly in yeah this Bishop would
love to come to this a 6 diagonal so
this is one option that black could have
gone for and I think this would have
been close to equality actually I'm not
sure what we might see from white here
maybe just Rickey 1 into Fischer basics
now maybe we'll bring this night around
still aiming for you know similar kinds
of ideas and you know black could also
just try to bring in his pieces as well
right and we might see some kind of
equality where black has some active
pieces on the Queen side White has some
active pieces on the Queen side I've
actually hung this pawn so maybe I'll
defend this pawn first before I do any
of this but you know black can also find
activity on the Queen side here and so
that's definitely I think the way black
should have gone for it because these
ideas of this King side attack are just
far too slow
especially against the structure with
the strong bishop on g2 it's tough to
generate threats against the white king
one other idea that I saw was maybe just
bringing this Knight over to d6 and
coming into this week see Foursquare
that black has some good control of we
might still see this 92 move and after
something like this maybe not have for
what the same idea but now maybe black
even has an option to play like a knight
b2 whenever he needs to just trade off
this Knight
you know for this strong piece as well
so a lot of options for black but you
know once you've allowed this weakness
kind of he's just far too behind to go
for this this King side attack he should
have just kind of met his opponent on
the Queen side or if he does go for this
attack like you said maybe he has to
commit a little bit harder I'm not sure
it would have worked out but definitely
dividing the forces like that was
something that that led to his downfall
yeah do you guys have any questions for
me about this game anything that doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense it's
pretty straightforward I think but some
places for confusion
yeah all right so I'm gonna move along
it's a game number two this one was
played between Alexander how chacon if
you want to pronounce it like that and
Max last name I definitely can't
pronounce we were actually talking about
this before we got started today your
weight there yeah close enough all right
is that close to your first language his
name or near enough near enough all
right
yeah we're fortunate enough to have a
tourist where're you from actually from
Finland's okay so slightly different
from from X we've but close enough to
know better pronunciations than me it's
great to have you here in the club but
all right so we saw a d4 d5 c4 c6 a Slav
black actually in this game captures on
c4 so we're definitely going to have a
different pawn structure at than last
game but in even in a structure like
this
we'll see eventually this pawn probably
false we still see two pawns versus
three so it's still going to be a
minority attack of sorts right and this
time it's gonna have different goals
than last time last time the goal was to
weaken this d5 pawn or this c6 pawn
right
whereas this time we'll see maybe some
slightly different goals in mind but you
can still you know kind of enact the
same plan we see white continue with a
for preventing this pawn from coming to
b5 trying to hold on to the c-4 upon
Bishop f5 developing the Bishop 95-97 so
white does get this pawn back it's a
very common line in the Slav Queen d7 we
see g3e 5d takes e5 95 this should bet
for this is still all known theory it
looks a little shaky for black but you
know it's got a good reputation
let me see Knight F to d7 Bishop g2 now
Bishop e6 and this is kind of the first
move the black deviated from theory any
Slav theoreticians in the house know
what black should play here no all right
well some common moves are actually this
pawn sacrifice with g5 which leads to
some very complicated lines if white
wants to try to capture this obviously
can't right away because of this night
so uh you know this forces some trades I
believe I don't know the theory on this
one - well I just know g5 is a move and
also the simpler kind of f6 just giving
this Knight another defender bring up
this night to jump into some good
squares where as Bishop e6 really not as
common not as common to see this move
wait goes ahead and captures on e5
Knight takes e5 of course you know this
Knight on c4 was attacked and white
simply castles here and once again this
position has been played I think around
30 times and almost always black plays
f6 simply adding the fender to this
tonight freeing up his other pieces and
in the game black played Bishop e7 and
already this is going to be kind of an
uncomfortable position for black one of
the reasons for which will actually see
coming up here so white just plays Queen
to c2 playing very simply getting his
Queen off the open file connecting the
rooks black goes and plays rook to d8
grabbing the open to file before white
can after riff to d1 black just castles
so both players have completed their
development but you know blacks pieces
are still kind of awkwardly placed right
not really exactly where he would want
them all to be white continues with a
knight to b5 move which is very
interesting so Brian okay all right I've
been handed a secret note but sure all
right
so Knight to b5 taking advantage of this
pin on the C file shut out by the way to
Ryan Chester chess club manager missed
his own livestream today
left it to me but so he does good work
here for us so taking advantage of this
e-file
like I said so of course you can't take
because the Queen's hanging and it's
already kind of making use of the shaky
placement of this Knight right the white
the black King would love to move away
somewhere but it's going to leave this
night behind hey welcome in the game we
actually saw you worked X t1 or a tix t1
and now Queen to a5 so the point here is
that of course if white wants to take
this piece black can take this piece in
exchange and it would be you know close
to a fair trade there are some
complications you know for example this
pawn is hanging but also this pawn is
hanging I'm not sure if black wants to
take it straight away maybe something
like b4 is a bit better taking advantage
of this bishop and if the bishop would
move maybe something like b3 and black
will probably regain this pawn or at
least something maybe not this exact
line but regardless white decided he
didn't like this night hanging and
simply played Knight to d4 in response
to this we saw a Bishop to c8 what black
didn't want to allow this knight to
capture on a6 and he couldn't really
find a better square for this bishop
right you can come out to g4 but you
might just get kicked around maybe not
with f3 maybe with h3 and you might find
yourself in some trouble actually after
move like I don't know Queen to e4 kind
of aiming indirectly at this bishop
right you got to be careful when you
make loose pieces like this I've talked
about this in a previous lecture and
apparently black you know knew about
this loose piece thing and how tactics
can arise so he just simply played
Bishop back to ca having the added bonus
of maybe defending this pawn if he ever
needs to push c5
and I'll leave you to find some
interesting moves for white here because
of white kind of does nothing blacks
going to eventually coordinators pieces
and his advantage might slip away but
white found some interesting ideas here
bishop or queenie for so that's
definitely some interesting stuff let's
see what do you think black might play
here what do I think black might play
here tough questions you might see this
f6 move again you might also see
something like Bishop to f6 simply you
know defending this Knight so Bishop
before instead maybe let us see the
Bishop e4 may be simply Knight g6 maybe
I don't know hah
I kind of don't want to play h6 I'll
stick with Knight g6 for the moment it's
kind of an awkward square but it gets
the job done
any further ideas here
mm maybe a little too crazy right I
don't know I might be fine giving up
this pawn if it means I can uh you know
take this guy or bring my queen over and
take this guy right give checks too it
looks pretty fun for black I don't think
I don't think that's quite good it's
maybe a different move here after Bishop
see a bishop I'm sorry
Bishop d2 maybe Bishop before is
possible for black though kind of
preventing this idea
yeah so again some some difficulties
right some difficulties it's tough to
you know get this pawn through if you're
allowing blacks some time to you know
kind of regroup so let's see what the
YouTube chats up to YouTube also thought
about Bishop d2 but yeah I like this
Bishop before move for black there right
it creates some problems also Knight f5
was suggested this move makes a lot of
sense but uh let's see I don't know the
proper square for this Bishop maybe
again just f6 and you can jump into d6
but already let's see
White has some choices here or black has
some choices here you could simply play
like rook to d8 and I don't think blacks
too upset about losing this bishop maybe
white won't take it of course but uh
yeah I don't see it immediately I don't
see it immediately for for white
alright Riddick's suggested pawn to b4
and then he said oops no but pawn to b4
is actually correct
so of course let's check the obvious
move first
you know Queen takes before losses of
course because it leaves this night
behind the less obvious Bishop takes b4
well more obvious for black less obvious
for whites deal with how do we want to
meet this smooth we need to find some
interesting tactics here to justify this
pawn to b4 move
oh yeah so sorry I'll jump back to this
but quickly the problem with 9f5 was
shown by the YouTube chat you can simply
take this and there's a tactic here to
look out for yeah but yeah I would agree
that position I was showing afternoon
enough I've looked pretty good for uh
for white but yeah unfortunate tactics
there Bishop takes Knight mmm what's
your plan after Queen takes Wow Bishop
c6 I am not entirely convinced that this
tactic works though it's an interesting
idea but maybe I can take and after take
so I can play Queen c5
yeah I might be holding my piece just
barely it's an awesome tactic though
well done on finding that
this one's pretty tough it has to do
with you know blacks loose pieces I've
talked about this in my lecture on you
know finding tactics in your games so
find all the loose pieces for black yes
yeah that's a great idea so first of all
loose pieces you mentioned the knight
this bishops also kind of loose right
it's kind of far advanced and it's only
defender is this Queen and so white
decided I'm gonna kick this Queen around
and you know that's how I started to
find these tactics and what's the only
square the Queen can go to the soul
defends the knight of course yeah Queen
c7 no real other choice and then again
white notice that these two pieces are
kind of loose and so a tactic arose in
the game
yeah Queen up so Queenie four was played
and let's see here some reason my
notation is not working I got caught in
the sideline disaster let's see no it's
okay
we just diverted from the game at some
point this wasn't exactly played because
you know black realized he can't take on
b4 of course and the reason is this and
so now if the bishop were to come to d6
let's see what can we do we have a
couple options yeah the most obvious
probably the best probably not the best
actually I don't think we can play rook
takes d6 I think we fall for our own
traps here and run into nut check
and takes here although I'm now seeing
maybe Bishop d6 and whites doing okay
but probably we don't want to snap off
this this bishop on d6 just yet I think
we have some other choices
so once again this piece is loose this
piece is loose is there anything we can
do to add an attacker to either of these
pieces
so we can't we can't end attacker this
sir what was that yeah Queen d4 it's a
great move adding another attacker to
this bishop and somehow blacks unable to
defend it again right can try your d8
but of course what is this run into this
one's not as hard
yeah but should be five right and you
know the bishop is pinned so you know
black would simply be losing a piece
here I'm not sure the exact best way for
him to give up the piece but either way
you know it's it's not gonna go well no
way to defend all stuff I think maybe he
can try something like g5 to displace
this bishop but of course you know black
started giving away too much with g5 you
know he's giving away this pawn
weakening his King and like where does
this Bishop even go for example I think
you actually have to play f6 here and
now maybe you can try your f d8 but
after something like Queen a7 you know
why it's simply going to be winning so
both of these players are very very good
and they both realized okay black can't
can't take here right which is why we
saw Queen c7 in the game but yeah pretty
you know complicated tactics all to
justify playing before right but you
know we got there in the end we got
there in the end
so of course this lecture is on the
minority attack what's the key move in
the minority attack b5 right so we see
b5 played here and again you know
there's no pawn on d5 this time so what
is this move really aimed at doing
because it's not about weakening the d5
pawn anymore
it's a little more abstract than than
attacking a weak pawn well I say that
but of course we are attacking a weak
pawn here but my point is you know black
can simply move this pawn and like let's
say we do nothing black and move this
other pawn right and then his pawns are
still strong
so what are we aimed what are we aiming
for instead of attacking these weak
pawns yeah Evan that's definitely part
of it we're definitely making this
bishop a lot better by breaking down
these pawns here we can see it's kind of
staring at nothing right it's staring at
this pawn on c6 but it's well defended
nothing to really be done and if we see
something like c5 get played of course
now the bishop is a lot stronger the
other thing is Kia central squares right
what are the four key central squares
that we all teach beginners of course
it's d 5v5 it's it's these four right
the four Center squares and so this pawn
forces black to give up this center
square on d5 which White's pieces are
actually well aimed at controlling and
so we'll see you later in the game white
actually makes use of this square right
so the minority attack doesn't always
have to be this thing you see only in
the Karlsbad structure you're only
attacking the d5 pawn on the c6 pawn it
can be more abstract than that you don't
have to win material all the time you
can just win key squares and activate
your pieces because of because of this
so in the game we do see c5 white of
course plays Knight to f5 you know
activating this piece there's no more
discovered you know discovered attack
tactics know that the queen is gone we
see f6 you know Bishop f5 not a move
black really wants to play anymore
because you know getting rid of this
defender of the C pawn or B pawn is
awkward
and let's see probably tactically
there's already some way to win I want
to say something like Queen e6 maybe in
takes and rook d7 you know it's it's
tough tough for black already so we
can't really take this Knight
we cf6 just defending this night black
is probably okay if if white takes here
I mean maybe his position still bed but
he's probably fine with that trade
specifically right listen it-it's pretty
strong this bishops pretty bad so what
do you think white did instead of takes
on e7
yes simply 93 again aimed at this key
square of d5 and so I mean you know
blacks kind of in trouble
he tried Bishop e6 to help control this
square but white now you know kind of
broke through what do you think the the
final move is to kind of launch into the
last series of moves that really really
shows black where his problems lie how
do you want to finish it off
yeah Bishop t5 is actually I think
absolutely right you know this bishop is
loose so black has to do something with
it and if you were to take here we would
simply see either 95 or @xt 5 in the
game we saw Arctic's quickly if
something like her to see a are between
to see it rather this probably leaves
behind a bit too much after something
like there should be 5 and I don't know
Queenie C 4 and this pawn is probably
gonna end up falling I mean you can try
it like rook f6 or something but of
course the main ideas of takes then the
spawn falls and if you try to defend the
way she began maybe already Knight g4
and you will pick up this pawn or at
least get in your rook and it's a very
pleasant endgame I don't think black
could try to hold it so black felt they
need to take and white actually does
capture with the rook instead of the
night you know the night is nice that it
attacks to pieces but maybe it's more
superficial than your it takes d5
because we might just move well we can't
move there we might just move here
keeping an eye on f6 and I don't
immediately see the knockout blow
maybe blacks gonna try to come here next
and hold on for dear life maybe it's not
going to work
but regardless 65 is a fine move we see
black play Queen a5 finally stepping out
of this pin and now simply Knight f5
taking advantage of this week Bishop we
see a check from black in Bishop d8 and
now a white simply plays takes and rook
d7 and the end is as near as you might
guess we see Bishop f6 played find the
fancy move that white shows here it's
fancy it's also probably the best move
but it's not key you know any move is
kind of winning here for white at this
point
yeah simply not age six we saw a similar
idea in the first game right of black
not being able to capture because of
three out of an age seven
so King h8 and now simply Queen c5 and
here black decided he was done and
resigned so yeah I mean another game
where things suddenly kind of fell apart
really quickly any questions about what
happened here and why black kind of fell
apart anything at all that you're kind
of unsure of in this game no all right
ya know yeah I mean it's kind of a weird
opening line to start out to start off
with right uh you don't usually see even
while it's still in theory you don't
usually see you know black having no
center pons like this kind of looks
unnatural to the eye and then having to
defend with this night back so yeah and
then that's kind of the moves that black
started playing wrong right it looks
kind of unnatural because it's kind of
wrong for it for black moving this
bishop again doesn't really make a whole
lot of sense to me it forces this trade
but maybe white isn't really unhappy
with this trade so again I think black
should've played something like f6 to
defend this night or you know there's
this also this g5 line which is a bit
more forcing but yeah simply Bishop e6
doesn't make a lot of sense and then
here even Bishop e7 doesn't make a whole
lot of sense either this Bishop might
want to go to other squares maybe even
d6 maybe b4 isn't as an idea but yeah i
mean ii seven is also just a bit too
slow so that's I think where black
actually went wrong is starting to stack
these pieces up rather and naturally so
yeah with that in mind I'm gonna move on
to our last game of the night probably
when we're running a bit short on time
so I'll go through a bit quickly this is
a game between McHale tau and semone or
however you pronounce that in Russian
not probably so molt but we see okay the
same structure the Carlsbad structure
and we see c-65 I'm going to go through
these moves really quickly so we can
reach Gio the part of the game that's
the minority attack both players develop
their pieces we see Knight F to d7 so I
will briefly mention a common idea when
you have less space in the opening which
I would say black has slightly less
space here is to trade off pieces right
you know you have less squares through
pieces so if you have less pieces it's
easier to find them squares so this is a
common idea for black is you know
offering the trade of these nights and
especially these bishops we see white
decline this trade because he has more
space he want
two key pieces on the board and of
course you know black still wants to
trade pieces so it gets off that net on
e5 place e6 here we see 9 a 4 and B 4
this is a different way of controlling
the c5 square and starting this attack
now if we were to see Bishop takes b4
you know White has a couple options one
of which I think would be simply Queen
b3 or rugby one I think I like Queen b3
and eventually you will have to give up
this b7 pawn so this bond is kind of
taboo for black she plays Bishop d6 8
instead again trading off White's
menacing pieces while he has less space
very uh you know logical we see wreck a
to be one now and mission takes g3 h6 g3
and finally a six from black so we see
kind of a similar setup for black
defending against this b5 break but you
know he kind of switches tactics later
on you see Ricky 7a for Erick's c7 rec
FC one queen e7 let me go and do this
Roka p3 g6 and Rick c3 rook c8 so why
does kind of been holding off on this b5
break why do you think that is compared
to the other game
well yeah but the way to get rid of this
b7 pawn is usually to play this b5 break
right and then you know take on c6
aiming for something like this great so
why is white delaying this what do you
think he's worried about yeah so you
know black doesn't always have to let
you capture on this square right and
here maybe blacks best try is to
actually just capture this guy and then
uh you know maybe play b6 himself and
he's got his pieces well placed for this
file right immediately this might you
know be slightly awkward for white
he might even lose material to some
tactic I don't see it immediately but
you know you can tell that his pieces
aren't exactly well placed to deal with
b5 and especially if we see all the way
back here you know now b5 would be a
pretty serious mistake because you know
this Queen is opposite this rook so why
are you trying to open this file right
it doesn't make as much sense so in this
game you know white took advantage of
this kind of structure and opted for a
different way to break through so any
ideas for White's tries to to break
through here
efore that's an interesting one you do
see this one sometimes maybe it's made
less effective by the damage to your
pawn structure on the Kings side a lot
of times we would see something like f3
2 e4 get played in this kind of
structure but playing efore alone well
it does have some advantages sometimes
it can leave behind some weak pawns
right well it would leave behind d4 but
here I'm pointing out if Knight d4 maybe
already this pawn is a bit weak
something like Bishop d5 you know
keeping an eye on this guy for the
moment but I think black is well-placed
to deal with you know even attacking
this deep on and you know preventing any
kingside nonsense you might be trying to
get with e4 it's a good idea though it's
a good idea to open it up piggy pig-pig
in the YouTube chat says it's towel so
he's got a sac something she's closer to
the truth than anybody here 96 clothes
96 is a good idea and maybe something
like b5 to follow right but uh perhaps
black can simply take this pawn and
let's see this also looks slightly
uncomfortable actually maybe I should
play better
let's see it takes here takes on a sec
so soon mm what do I think
what do I think
yeah maybe queen before and this is this
is gonna be slightly awkward for black
but uh maybe not losing or anything
don't know if I can get away with this
move just yet I'll play like King g7
maybe and you do have this past a pawn
but I do have two pieces for this rook
maybe I can try and hold on in the Sun
game and I don't know I don't know what
white found an even more forcing way at
the knight takes a six though maybe you
Knight takes a six is also fine but I
get the feeling there's gonna be some
refutation
yeah so Knight takes b7 so what do you
play going right at the heart of the
matter
taking the spine off the board see again
I'm not too sure with the refutation 296
is maybe we'll take a look at that
after we finished but see Knight b7 rook
d7 Bishop basics and now you know of
course the tharixer skewered or pinned
however you want to say it rec AAA takes
takes and now you know white has
achieved what he wanted he got these two
pawns in the rook for his two pieces but
he still has to find some accurate
follow-ups here in the game you played
Queen b3 defending both these pawns
before capturing here let's see we see a
rook to a6 now defending this guy so we
still need that final way to break
through so once again the key move and
all minority attack positions even when
you're down you know piece wise and
material may be up and and if you count
the pawns as well but it's b5 right
getting these rooks into the game
opening up this C file or weakening this
pawn and so now we see C takes B and now
tell actually doesn't recapture right
away he throws in this annoying rook c7
move oh we see Queen b6 now and now it's
all continued to be annoying I think and
actually played a b5 and here find the
move for white there are a few moves
almost all of them are winning but he
played a very interesting way to kind of
force matters force pieces off the board
and force himself into a dead winning
endgame
well
yeah maybe you're giving up a bit too
much maybe a bit too much I know you're
pretending to be towel but yeah I'm not
sure I see the follow up immediately
yeah I don't know I'm thinking or exceed
six but what can what can black do maybe
black can do this move and be annoying
this looks like it might be trying to
hold in some fashion I don't trust it
but yeah Rick ups have an interesting
idea but all right all right all right
if you're gonna make me claim that this
is actually not losing let's see I can
check you
I do like giving check so that's my
favorite things in this world maybe I've
got problems here though
I might come back
yeah maybe you have check but it's
annoying
okay maybe not rook b5 let's see let's
see let's see Queen B 7 is this a move I
can get away with Navy I don't know this
is added to the list of things to check
but we do have to keep moving here so
the move played in the game was actually
the interesting rook 1 to c6
I believe forcing Queen takes b5 and
after Queen b5 or fb5
there's no way to save this bishop of
course you know he tried bishop de 8 but
after rook to c8 once again it's kind of
a skewer kind of a pin depending on how
you phrase it we see King g7 and now
simply ripped to f3 no way to defend the
bishop so the bishop would have to move
and then of course the knight is hanging
and the game black tried repeat 1 check
King h2 Knight to d7 and resigns here
after losing well I guess not losing
yeah losing another piece has something
like this so let's go back to 96 here do
you guys mind if I just cheat cheating
makes my life easier if you really want
to know the answer let's do it
so yeah Bishop basics and I simply rook
b8 here not giving up the exchange
actually I was worried about b5 but
apparently stockfish doesn't care simply
Bishop e8 and yeah this looks like a
position maybe black slightly better
maybe white has some chances but and
that would be the problem and let's see
something like that wouldn't work after
97 because of course there's no way to
decline giving up the exchange you're
forced to give it up after that let's
take a look here so Rick f7
f7 king f7 I take go here oh you're
still winning congratulations yet I'm
not I don't fully remember it was played
I think you tried her xt6 which I guess
I can just take this pawn
and not worry about a thing because of
King h8 I don't know
ambitious stuff but stockfish holds it
but yeah I've currently after rook c5
you're slightly better which is
believable any other questions about
this game yeah move 16 b5 yes
so this is another way for black try to
deal with this structure change right
you can try to prevent the minority
attack by playing b5 himself and this
does show up in a lot of lines but you
know it's not a perfect solution for
black right there's still problems in
that this pawn on c6 is still gonna be
weak right and in addition to that it
really does give up this Square and kind
of beyond hope of recovery so we might
just see something like 95 I'm not sure
maybe a 5 for black is something you've
seen yeah 97 maybe let's see here
I mean in this specific position like
White has ways to try to keep the piece
on maybe something like Knight to be 7
Queen c8 and something like neck here
and maybe actually it's better to just
try it off this piece and I don't know
perhaps just stack up on the C pawn you
might play your c8 oh I don't know let's
see might play a 4 if I must I might I
might do it
that's another thing I have I also just
have Bishop age seven right yeah I
missed that immediately so maybe so yes
sorry b5 here so maybe ninety-seven
doesn't work immediately because of this
Bishop h7 idea other than that yeah I
think the safe five move is a common
thing black can try and let's see I
don't know maybe a three takes takes
Queen b6 maybe this looks like stuff
people might try right but yeah I mean
in the ends you're just gonna have some
pressure on this pawn if you can
maneuver your pieces around such that
you know it kind of works out for you
that's that's basically the thing you
have to try and this b5 move from luck
it's a good defensive idea but it's
never really in my opinion playing for
an advantage right Black's simply saying
alright I'm gonna lock down your pawns
on the Queen side hopefully you can't
find a way to win ce6 if that's true
then I'm gonna be equal if that's false
then I'm gonna lose c6 and probably the
game right the only thing to be careful
of is to make sure you have this pawn
well under control and you do want to be
cautious of this idea if you know it
comes in some position where this Knight
gets stuck on like c3 then it's gonna be
a little bit worse for you right because
you don't get this strong piece coming
in to c5 but yeah this normally should
be fine for white I can check everything
I just said with the engine it looks
like we're plus one here which is an
understandable evaluation it wants to
break things open immediately it was
something like efore which also makes
sense you know eyeing this week pawn
again right off the bat let's see it
just likes Knight c5 and something like
a 5 or even giving up this Bishop and
yeah already actually white wants to
play a 4 so this is another way of
handling it is playing a 4 immediately
and again just just ripping open the
Queen sight well while blacks kind of
messing around playing a lot of pawn
moves any other questions about the
minority attack in general or this game
no all right I'm gonna call it here then
I think we ran just a tad over time but
yeah thanks guys for coming out to the
lecture I thought it was an interesting
one thanks YouTube viewers for joining
me here and yeah see you next time on
the road to 2000
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]